the diversity of space objects scattered
across vast expanses of the universe
can't but amaze
with some of them barely visible against
the dark background of the cosmos others
can easily be observed billions of light
years away
gravitationally bound in space they form
unique elaborate structures such as
planetary systems star clusters or
galaxies
today we're going to visit some of the
most exciting ones
first of all we'll drop in on some
remarkable systems within 50 light years
from the earth
after that we'll set out to see
westerlund 1 which will be followed by a
tour around the most horrifying planets
known to science today after leaving the
milky way we'll check out several
unusual galaxies
this detour will be followed by a visit
to practically the very edge of the
universe to a remote micro quasar dubbed
ss433
the return trip home will be a long one
and we'll have plenty of time to ponder
the question why the universe is the way
it is now
what lies at the basis of its laws
and how would it be different if the
values of the fundamental constants were
different from the ones we know
the anthropic principle may well supply
answers to these tricky philosophical
questions
ready
let's get to it
[Music]
cosmo
the first in outer space
there are approximately 1
400 stellar systems in space within the
radius of 50 light years from the solar
system
some of them are multiple and contain
two and more objects which makes the
overall number of our stellar neighbors
over two thousand
these are all sorts of stars from dim
red dwarves to dazzling giants whose
temperatures are beyond our imagination
the incredible scale and great abundance
of space objects and all their diversity
can't but amaze
life's too short to give account of each
and every one of them
right now we're going to travel at
incredible speeds by far faster than the
speed of light
it will take us just a few minutes to
cover dozens of light years of space
we'll get to check out quite a few
remarkable space objects around the
solar system
other worlds and stars are already
waiting
after we fly around proxima centauri a
detour of 11 light years that would have
passed in the blink of an eye where in
the environs of the dim red dwarf known
as ros128
we can't see it from the earth with a
naked eye
on pre-possessing though it may seem
there is an earth-like exoplanet dubbed
ros128b orbiting this star
this exoplanet is one of the closest to
us
unlike the yet closer and cooler proxima
centauri b
the temperature on dros 128b is
relatively moderate ranging from -60 to
plus 21 degrees celsius
assuming its surface to be identical to
that of our planet which absorbs 70
percent of the light shed on it the
equilibrium temperature of ros128b is
estimated at around seven degrees
celsius
it is eight degrees cooler than that of
today's earth but quite enough to
sustain life
the exoplanet's mass is roughly 35
percent bigger than that of the earth
the radius hasn't been accurately
measured at this point
but provided the planet's composition is
similar to our earth's its diameter is
supposed to be roughly 10 percent bigger
than that of the earth
the free fall acceleration on its
surface is expected to be just 12
percent bigger than that on our planet
if all these estimations are correct
then the conditions on the surface of
rospan 28b are supposed to be comparable
with those on the earth
besides the system is rapidly moving to
meet the sun
in just 79 000 years it will be closer
to us than proxima centauri which is
moving away from us
quite like most exoplanets we know of
ros128b is located quite close to its
host star
the distance from it to the center of
the system is just 0.05 astronomical
units or 20 times shorter than the
distance between the earth and the sun
it takes the exoplanet slightly under 10
days to complete a full orbit around its
star
it is also thought that it must be
tidally locked
speaking about its host star ros 128 its
mass is approximately 17 percent that of
the sun with the radius measuring around
0.2 that of the sun
the star's surface temperature is twice
as low as out of the sun
at
3192 kelvin and its luminosity is
roughly 300 times lower than that of the
sun
it's worth mentioning that dros 128 is a
comparatively quiet star
with its luminosity quite stable and
regular
it hardly ever flares up or emits
stellar matter so pernicious for all
living things
moving on through space 12 light years
in the direction pointing away from the
sun we will see lightens star also known
as gj273
it boasts one of the largest planetary
systems detected in the space nearest to
us
the star itself is a red dwarf of an
orange hue whose mass is just 25 that of
the sun
its radius is three times smaller than
that of the sun and its luminosity is
435 times lower so it's hardly
surprising that it can only be seen
through a telescope
it is quite an exciting star because
there are as many as four objects
detected in its environs two of which
are confirmed exoplanets
the other two are still prospective
candidates awaiting confirmation
the first confirmed exoplanet was dubbed
light and b it was detected thanks to
high precision measurement of the star's
proper motion the object's mass is
estimated to be about 2.89 times that of
the earth its radius is 35 percent
bigger than that of our planet
this makes the object a super earth and
its surface gravity may turn out to be
suitable for humans
the distance between the system's center
and light and b equals roughly 0.1
astronomical units although the amount
of light received by the exoplanet from
its parent star is comparable with that
received by us from the sun
thus light and b lies in its star's
habitable zone and may well be
considered a potential candidate for
searching for alien life the equilibrium
surface temperature of the planet is 259
to 292 kelvin or minus 14 to plus 19
degrees celsius
this makes the conditions on light and b
quite suitable for humans
the other confirmed exoplanet in the
system is light and sea
with this space object's mass similar to
that of the earth it lies much closer to
its host star the exact parameters of
its orbit haven't been defined yet but
it is known that it takes the object
just 4.7 days to complete a full orbit
around its system's center
it is likely that this is a scorching
hot and harsh celestial body without any
atmosphere with one on the same side
facing the star at all times
the two other objects in the system were
discovered in 2019 and are still
awaiting confirmation of their status
according to preliminary estimates there
are ice giants with masses from 5 to 15
times out of the earth with the radii of
their orbits lying within 0.8
astronomical units their orbital periods
cannot be over
558 days
lighten is a relatively cold star and
with these two objects lying beyond its
habitable zone their temperatures are
almost certainly extremely low
it goes without saying that at this
stage these two candidates still want
further exploration
moving on and away from the lighting
system we will come across a star known
as outair lying 16.8 light years away
from the earth it is a bright white blue
star
its mass is around 1.8 that of the sun
and its age is estimated at around 1.2
billion years
this star's luminosity is 11 times that
of the sun
which makes it one of the most
conspicuous objects in our night sky
another curious feature about air is its
rotation which is remarkably fast
thus it spins on its axis approximately
67 times faster than the sun it
completes a full rotation within
slightly less than nine hours the
velocity of star material at the equator
equals about
286 kilometers per second due to this
outstandingly rapid rotation the star's
shape is far from an ideal sphere the
star's equatorial diameter is 22 percent
bigger than the distance between its
poles and is roughly twice the diameter
of the sun
the star's shape can't but affect its
temperature and luminosity
which also differ in its different areas
the stellar matter in the equatorial
zone of the star is noticeably colder
and darker than in the poles
the temperature of the equator is just
6900 kelvin the poles meanwhile are as
hot as 8
500 kelvin which is around 8
200 degrees celsius
interestingly the fact that altair has
an irregular shape was first arrived at
following theoretical calculations
only later in 2007 was it finally
confirmed after an image of the star was
produced where it is seen to have a
disk-like shape
actually altair happened to become the
first star beyond the solar system whose
surface had been imaged
unfortunately no planet has been
detected in altair's environs still
observations show rings or a fog of gas
enveloping the star
altair's light is dispersed in these
structures which produces a curious
effect
this major interference of light results
in a humongous rainbow around the star
on the downside however even though it
looks fascinating and majestic it partly
conceals this style and so greatly
hampers studying it
as we carry on on our way through space
we will get as far as thermal health
lying 25 light years away from the earth
this stellar system consists of three
components for a long time the three
components making it up used to be
considered mutually independent space
objects
then in 2013
evidence showed that they're in fact
gravitationally bound forming a large
and single structure in space
thermal howd is probably the widest
multiple star system located close to
ours the biggest distance between its
components reaches 3.2 light years
incidentally almost 11 lunar discs may
be placed in our night sky between the
remotest objects in the thermal health
system
the largest most well-known and
well-seen component of the system is
referred to as thermal health a
it's a young and hot star whose mass is
92 percent bigger than that of the sun
with its radius measuring around 1.85
times that of the sun
it was this star that people have
referred to as thermal held since
ancient times
quite unaware of the fact that there are
other not so easily observable
components in this system
the star's luminosity is remarkably high
at 16 times that of the sun
its temperature is estimated at roughly
8 500 kelvin or 8
200 degrees celsius
thermal health could be as old as 400 to
480 million years
according to today's models of stellar
evolution the star may grow to be around
1 billion years old
on reaching this age it will more likely
than not go supernova and turn into a
white dwarf
thermal health a is surrounded by a disk
of protoplanetary gas and dust
divided into several segments its inner
radius is 133 astronomical units with a
width measuring about 25 astronomical
units
this disc is thought to be an active
stellar nursery with celestial bodies
regularly born there
that is why it is an area of keen
interest for astronomers
it used to be thought that there was a
massive planet lurking somewhere in
formal house environs it was even given
a name
dagon
however further observations showed that
there was hardly any planet there after
all
it must have been a wide cloud of dust
that was taken for an exoplanet it would
have originated on collision of
asteroids and comets
point nine light years away from the
main component of the system there lies
fomo how to be
also known as tw pisces or striny
it's an orange dwarf with a mass around
70 percent that of the sun with its
radius roughly 63 percent that of the
sun
the star's surface temperature is
estimated at approximately four thousand
seven hundred kelvin which is four
thousand four hundred degrees celsius
interestingly the star's luminosity is
much lower than that of the sun
our host star is five times brighter
in 2019 on carrying out spectral and
proper motion analysis scientists put
forward the suggestion that there might
be a celestial body as heavy as 0.6 to
1.9 jupiter masses orbiting the star the
existence of this body still remains to
be confirmed and its exact orbits
parameters calculated precisely
at this point preliminary estimations
show that it should take the
hypothetical planet 25 years to complete
a full orbit around its host's star
the third star in the thermal howard
system is lp876-10
it is a red dwarf lying two and a half
light years away from the main component
of the system the star is five times
lighter than the sun
and its surface temperature is slightly
over 3100 kelvin
it takes lp
876-10 approximately 20 million years to
complete a full orbit around thermal
health a apparently the red dwarf would
have orbited its big brother just 22
times since the birth of the system as
for planets or exoplanet candidates none
of these have so far been detected near
the star
still observations allow us to suppose
that there is a cloud of gas and dust
around it whose radius is anything from
10 to 40 astronomical units
our next and final destination for today
is 37.3 light years away from the earth
that's the distance we would have
covered now to reach arcturus the
brightest star in the northern
hemisphere and the fourth brightest star
in the night sky
the star is the main component of a
binary star system it is an orange giant
whose life is now slowly drawing to a
close
most of its hydrogen has already been
transformed into helium and now the star
is busy burning the remains of its
stellar fuel and gradually expanding in
size
arcturus is also the brightest star of a
great stellar stream named in its honor
this gargantuan structure is in fact the
debris of a dwarf galaxy absorbed by the
milky way some 2 billion years ago
it contains 53 stars
most of them are old and dim and not
nearly as impressive as arcturus
arcturus emits 170 times as much
luminous energy as the sun although its
surface temperature is much lower
at just
4251 kelvin
it is thought that this giant used to be
quite like our sun because its mass is
just 10 percent bigger but what with the
inevitable depletion of its stellar fuel
and the inner pressure with scorching
hot plasma the star turned into an
orange giant whose radius is now 25
times that of the sun
according to today's theory of stellar
evolution
this is something that our sun is
expected to go through in the distant
future too
arcturus's age is gauged at anything
from six to eight and a half billion
years
it is hard to predict when it will go
supernova at the end of its life cycle
but it will happen quite soon in
astronomical terms
shedding its outer layers arcturus will
become a scorching hot white dwarf
destined to slowly cool off in the
course of billions of years to follow
the second component of the system is
barely visible against the background of
its giant companion
this small star with luminosity 20 times
lower than that of arcturus lies so
close to it that it's hardly possible to
define its parameters
even if some planets did manage to form
in this stellar system many millions of
years ago they must have been absorbed
by arcturus itself
either way no objects have been detected
in the stars and virus at this point
a star cluster is a group of stars which
formed from one in the same gigantic
cloud of interstellar mata
these stars are practically identical in
terms of their chemical composition and
age the system they form is bound by
gravity forces
star clusters fall into either of these
two categories which are the main
varieties open and globular clusters
open star clusters are products of
stellar nurseries evolution
the latters are areas of cosmic gas
where stars are actively born
that is why the clusters here are mainly
comprised of young stars and great
amounts of interstellar hydrogen
gravity forces between them are
comparatively feeble which leads to an
open cluster's disintegration several
hundred million years after its
formation which of course is mere
seconds in astronomical terms some of
its former members still stick together
in their joint movement in space thus
forming a stellar stream while others
break away from their group to become
sole masters of their own destiny
over
1100 open star clusters have been
pinpointed in our galaxy and
incidentally it appears to be just a
tiny portion of their overall count
globular clusters are larger and denser
than open ones and consist of old and
not very massive stars the average
distance between the stars there is four
to six light months as for their masses
these may reach a million times that of
the sun
the milky way contains not less than 150
star clusters of this type and the
andromeda galaxy over 500
open clusters are comparatively modest
in size but the star count in some of
them reaches thousands these objects are
referred to as superstar clusters
the largest of them are thought to
eventually turn into globular ones all
it will take is waiting around for a few
billion years or so until the most
massive stars there have burned out and
exploded
one of the largest superstar clusters in
our galaxy is one referred to as
westerland one it was spotted back in
1961 by swedish astronomer banked
westerland but for a long while remained
largely understudied as it is quite
difficult to observe
the distance from the cluster's center
to the solar system has been estimated
at approximately 10 000 to 15 000 light
years staggering though this figure may
seem
westerlund 1 is in fact one of our
closest superstar clusters that is why
it is crucial to observe it to bring our
understanding of stellar evolution
processes to a whole new level
the diameter of westerland one measures
around seven light years astoundingly
this area which is really tiny in
astronomical terms is literally crammed
with thousands of stars with a total
mass of about 63 000 solar masses
some straightforward calculations show
the distances between the major members
of the cluster are just several light
months as for binary system components
they are much closer to each other than
that
due to incredible density of the stars
in the cluster and the clouds of
interstellar gas the stars are shrouded
in it is impossible to distinguish the
exact sources of light here as the
thousands of stars this light comes from
are too densely packed this greatly
interferes with observations and doesn't
allow the observer to count the stars
that is why the exact stark out and
westerland one remains to be gauged
among them the following types of stars
have already been pinpointed
six yellow hypergiants four red
supergiants
twenty-four wolf rajat stars and a
supergiant with a highly peculiar
emission spectrum supposedly it formed
on collision of two massive stars
in addition there is a great number of
hot blue giants and an x-ray pulsar
discovered among the stars in the
cluster the pulsar is an anomalous
object a neutron star spinning with a
mind-boggling spade the binary star
count is also quite high in westerland
1.
this fact may be accounted for by the
high density of the cluster's objects
all the superstar clusters objects are
posited to have formed at round 1 at the
same time
however depending on a type of stars
they differ in terms of their rage too
to start with according to today's
theory of stellar evolution red
supergiants cannot be younger than four
million years wolf rayet stars on the
other hand which are in the final stage
of their life cycle by definition are
remarkably numerous in the cluster
their life expectancy is known almost
never to have been over 5 million years
thus the age of westerlund 1 is quite
accurately estimated at a mere four to
five million years
which in essence is seconds in
astronomical terms
at approximately the same time it was
forming first australopithecus and
saber-toothed tigers roamed the earth
and all that had been left of dinosaurs
by then was just their fossilized
remains
mathematical modelling of the cluster's
formation shows that the cluster may
have contained 50 to 150 heavy stars
that would have depleted their resources
by now and so would have come to the
final stage of their life cycle
given the estimates are correct on
average there would have been supernovae
every 10 000 years in the course of the
past million years
as we know the heavier a star the faster
it comes to the end of its life cycle
and goes supernova after which it leaves
a black hole
neutron star or white dwarf however to
date only one object like that has been
detected it is thought that many
supermassive stars would have turned
into black holes but these are rather
difficult to spot today
the superstar cluster westerlund 1
contains one of the largest stars known
today designation westerlund 126
since it is rather difficult to observe
it its radius has been gauged at roughly
to
2500 times that of the sun
if its radius is closer to the bigger
margin
westerland 126 may be the biggest star
known to mankind
however the radius is more likely to lie
closer to the lower margin and measure
slightly over 1
500 times that of the sun
even so if its center were to be
theoretically placed in that of the sun
westerland 126 would cover all the
planets reaching as far as the orbit of
jupiter
the supergiant's luminosity is
approximately three hundred and eighty
thousand times that of the sun
although its surface temperature is
comparatively low just around three
thousand kelvin the star's mass hasn't
been gauged yet but today's perception
of stellar evolution allows us to assume
that it may be around 20 solar masses
another unusual object in the cluster is
a magnetar with a name like a tongue
twister it is also the most powerful
source of x-ray radiation in that area
of space
located approximately 16 000 light years
from the sun it is a neutron star whose
rotation period is about 10 seconds
incidentally this is rather slow in
comparison to other objects of this
class those rotate several times a
second
given that all the stars in the cluster
formed at around 1 at the same time it
would have taken the star that was the
progenitor of this magnetar just 5
million years to deplete its
thermonuclear fuel this means that when
it was born its mass should have been
not less than 40 solar masses
however in that case it should have left
a black hole rather than a neutron star
after going supernova
it transpires that the progenitor star
had to unaccountably lose up to 95
percent of its mass before going
supernova
one of the possible answers to this
riddle may lie in the fact that the
object may have originated from a binary
star rather than a single one
by spinning around their common mass
center at an astounding rate the
system's components had a chance of
actively exchanging material at some
point the supernova would have scattered
most of this material in the space
around it while the second component
would have been ejected from the system
the star westerlund 1 5 which is located
comparatively close to the magnetar may
well have been that very component
although it is not certain
unfortunately chances of discovering any
planets in the superstar cluster
westerland one are thin first of all the
stars the cluster is comprised of are
too young for any planets to form in
their environs this curious process
takes hundreds of millions of years at
the very least
secondly
even billions of years later when the
cluster supposedly turns into a globular
one it is hardly worthwhile to
anticipate any objects to be born there
that would potentially be capable of
sustaining life the close proximity of
large and heavy stars makes the
potential planets orbits unstable
moreover in certain circumstances a
massive neighbor relatively close to a
star system
may actually destroy it completely
besides thousands of active stars
concentrated in a small area of space
create a remarkably powerful radiation
background frequent flares of supernovae
occurring in this crammed space may
cause harmful gamma-ray bursts which
destroy any life on a planet's surface
chances are that even if mankind finds a
way to cover interstellar distances
clusters will still remain deadly areas
for quite a while
shortly before halloween in 2020 nasa
compiled a list of the most terrifying
worlds
among others they included six
exoplanets
each of these objects environments is
not just extremely harsh for any living
organism even finding oneself in their
comparatively close proximity may prove
to be fatal
the first object on the list is a black
gas giant designation tres 2b
this celestial object orbits the star
tres2 which is a yellow dwarf lying as
far as 718 light years away from us
let's take a closer look at it
due to some unique properties of the
chemical composition of the surface of
tres-2b
the planet absorbs over 99 of all the
light shed on it the nature of these
properties remains a mystery and chances
are there are some chemical reactions
taking place on the surface that we have
never registered on any similar object
before
and it is these properties that make
tres 2b the darkest exoplanet on the
astronomical map of today
this gas giant was discovered on the
21st of august 2006
with more details on its characteristics
obtained several years later
the mass of tres 2b is 1.2 jupiter
masses and its radius measures 1.27
times that of jupiter
the atmosphere is as scorching as 1000
degrees celsius which gives the
exoplanet a faint red glow like that of
embers
still in spite of its gloomy looks tres
2b doesn't really qualify to be called
the most dangerous place in the universe
there are many more objects lurking in
space that are more terrifying than that
let's see some more inhospitable ones
here is another exoplanet designation 55
cancri e
it lies in the system of a sun-like star
designation 55 cancri a
this celestial object was discovered on
the 30th of august 2004 by the doppler
spectroscopy method let's look at it in
more detail the planet's mass equals
approximately 8 earth masses and its
radius measures 1.875
of the earth
55 cancri e is tidally locked and so it
is always daytime on one side and night
time on the other that is why the side
facing the host star is always heated up
to a temperature reaching
2400 degrees celsius
with the temperature on the night side
1300 degrees celsius
these values are so high because the
distance between the planet and its
parent star is just 0.0183
astronomical units
besides volcanism on 55 cancri e which
is thought likely to be there causes
dust clouds emissions
these clouds trap hate and effectively
prevent it from escaping into space
the planet's orbital period is slightly
under 18 hours
as for the atmospherical makeup there is
helium and hydrogen registered in it
there are also large amounts of carbon
incidentally this element is likely to
form thick layers of graphite and
diamonds in the planet's interior
55 cancri e isn't the only object in the
planetary system of its host star
there are four other celestial objects
orbiting it the environments on these
are by far more hospitable
which is the feature by which the 55
cancri a system differs from the
following object
it is dubbed poltergeist or psr 1257
plus 12c
this is an exoplanet lying in a pulsar
system
the celestial object is located just
0.36
astronomical units from the system's
center
this shows that poltergeist wouldn't
have survived a supernova that must have
taken place before the pulsar had been
formed
consequently the exoplanet is likely to
have formed after this tremendous event
with the material for it coming from the
nebula left after the explosion
according to another hypothesis the
pulsar may have formed after the merging
of two white dwarfs
unlike with a supernova this process
isn't always accompanied by a powerful
blast
still as this is the first object of its
kind we have discovered science cannot
give a definite answer as to its origins
the system with a celestial object lies
300 light years from the earth
its mass is approximately four times
that of our planet
as for its orbital period it is around
66 days
incidentally the outstandingly powerful
radiation emitted by the pulsar is
enough to crumple any spaceship wanting
to approach the mysterious exoplanet in
its system
even with all these properties taken
into account portuguese does not really
qualify as the most dangerous exoplanet
known to us
on approaching it an astronomical body
may simply get destroyed but it would
get positively vaporized in close
proximity to the following object
the reason for this effect is the
extremely high temperature on kepler-70b
which is the hottest exoplanet known to
us
the object orbits the sub-dwarf star
kepler-70
with a surface temperature higher than
that on our sun it reaches
6800 degrees celsius the object's mass
equals 0.44 earth masses and its radius
measures 0.76 that of the earth
the celestial object's orbital period is
345 minutes
in other words a day here is less than
six hours long
interestingly the exoplanet regularly
passes another object in the system
kepler-70c at a distance of 240 000
kilometers
to date this is the closest that planets
in space have been registered to pass
each other
the extremely high temperature on
kepler-70b could be accounted for by the
fact that this object may once have been
part of its parent star
as for giving it the status of an
exoplanet it will take more evidence to
confirm that it deserves to be given it
so this remains an open question
it should be mentioned that kepler-70b
is not the only celestial object we know
of that interacts with its parent star
so closely
another object in similar conditions is
the exoplanet known as wasp-12b
this celestial body lies
870 light years away from our system its
radius measures 1.93 times that of
jupiter and its mass equals 1.46 jupiter
masses
wasp-12b is just 0.03 astronomical units
away from its parent star
due to this close proximity the
exoplanet has a temperature reaching as
much as
2200 degrees celsius the host star's
extremely powerful gravitation slowly
absorbs wasp-12b
eventually in approximately 10 million
years time the exoplanet is expected to
be destroyed completely
bearing all this in mind we will
probably never delve any deeper into the
nature of this exoplanet
it would appear that studying worlds of
this kind cannot be high on scientists
list of priorities
however some of these objects may happen
to have some really unique features
seemingly quite plain and ordinary
worlds like that may conceal many more
dangers than would appear at first
glance
when flying past the celestial body
hd189733b
for example one might complacently think
it a safe planet as it resembles our
earth by its looks
but if one were to get as low as the
level of its atmosphere one would be
exposed to some life-threatening dangers
for a start the object's winds carry
particles of silicate and develop
velocities of 8
700 kilometers per hour
besides the rains on this planet cause
precipitations of molten glass
the reasons for such hazardous weather
conditions are extremely high
temperatures and the atmosphere's
peculiar chemical composition
speaking about the exoplanet's orbital
period it is approximately 2.5 days
and it is highly likely that the object
is tidally locked to its parent star
[Music]
as usual a quick overview of its main
characteristics
hd189733b is a bright blue gas giant
orbiting an orange dwarf in the
constellation vulpecular it lies just 63
light years away from our system
the object's diameter is 1.1 times that
of jupiter
and as for its mass it is
113 percent that of jupiter
interestingly the distance between
hd189733b
and its star is 30 times less than the
distance between the earth and the sun
and equals approximately 5 million
kilometers
due to its close proximity to the parent
star it has a constant surface
temperature of as high as around
930 degrees celsius on the dayside with
the temperature on the night side never
dropping below
425 degrees celsius
immediately on being discovered the
celestial body became a subject of
investigations
in 2007 thanks to data obtained by the
hubble telescope scientists found out
that hd189733b
has a foggy atmosphere
interestingly when the planet transits
between the observer on the earth and
its star its atmosphere assumes a
reddish hue
this effect could possibly be caused by
the haze in the atmosphere
according to preliminary estimates it
consists of particles of iron silicates
and aluminium oxide
apart from that the information beamed
back by the hubble telescope helped
scientists establish that the planet's
atmosphere contains water vapour neutral
oxygen and an organic methane compound
additional investigations revealed the
presence of carbon monoxide on the day
side of the planet
what prompted most questions however was
the results of investigations revealing
traces of methane of an unusual variety
in the planet's atmosphere this chemical
element was shown to be in a peculiar
fluorescent state when it emits
electromagnetic radiation in the
infrared range
this state of the substance is
indicative of some unknown activity in
the atmosphere of the exoplanet which
still remains to be found out
this is quite a clear-cut example of a
situation when investigating an object
like an exoplanet with an exceptionally
harsh environment may yield unexpected
results about some processes taking
place there that will be a valuable
contribution to science
and as the process of studying these
worlds continues
they will remain no other than horror
planets to us as well as a solid
reminder that we're more than just lucky
to be the dwellers of our earth
distances from the milky way to other
galaxies are by all accounts
mind-boggling as a rule it is anything
from millions to billions of light years
due to the universe's cosmological
expansion the distance between the earth
and any remote object in the universe is
constantly growing which makes the light
emanating from this object look redder
than it actually is
this phenomenon is known as a redshift
it is of great help in gauging distances
and velocities on the astronomical scale
alternatively some galaxy's spectrum is
blue shifted which means that they're
not on an escape trajectory from us but
on the contrary are moving to meet us
one of these unusual space objects is
the galaxy m86 in the virgo cluster
roughly 52 million light years away from
the sun it is moving towards the milky
way at a speed of around
244 kilometers per second which makes it
one of the fastest moving blue shifted
galaxies
by moving to high speed through the
scattered gas the virgo cluster is
filled with m86 is constantly shedding
its own interstellar mata
as a result of this process it leaves a
trail of long lines of warm ionized
hydrogen behind
m86 is connected with the almost
destroyed spiral galaxy ngc 4438 with
several of these filaments
these two galaxies are thought to have
collided at some point in the distant
past which was the smaller ones undoing
interestingly m86 is known to have
destroyed its other neighbors in the
past as well
several stellar streams have been
detected in its halo that are likely to
be the remains of smaller galaxies
absorbed earlier
an impressive number of globular
clusters in its structure is another
outstanding feature of m86
observations show that their number is
upwards of 3
and 800 which is around 25 times as many
as in the milky way
there is a theory that claims these
clusters to be the remains of dwarf
galaxies that m86 would have absorbed in
the past
if it really is the case
then it would have destroyed tens or
even hundreds of other galaxies
having said that m86 looks anything but
unique the galaxy eso 137-001
which we'll be looking at next has a
similar shape
but unlike m86 it appears more
outlandishly original
located
227 million light years away from the
sun it is as heavy as 5 to 14 billion
solar masses
as for its stars most of them are young
and bright blue giants iso
137-001 in its turn is part of a bell
3627 a large galaxy cluster
moving to its center at an incredible
speed of almost 2 000 kilometers per
second the galaxy collides with
interstellar gas pressure inside the
cluster
as a result its own gas is blown out
leaving behind tails that stretch for up
to two hundred and sixty thousand light
years
incidentally the mass of interstellar
gas in those areas is due to four times
that of the gas inside the galaxy it is
hardly surprising that star bursts are a
common thing here
that is stars don't stop forming in
these enormous streams made up mostly of
hydrogen when seen from the side eso
137-001 appears like a giant jellyfish
floating through endless expanses of
space
unfortunately as the galaxy is
continuously stripped of its
interstellar gas its life expectancy
diminishes too
with not much material left no new stars
can form here which greatly affects the
structure of the spiral arms and central
bulge of the galaxy
on the bright side scientists have a
chance of finding out more about dark
matter and its interaction with other
space objects by observing the behavior
of the gas streams left in the galaxy's
wake
speaking about the formation of new
stars there is a galaxy with a name that
speaks for itself
baby boom
around 4 000 stars are born here every
year which is about 400 times more than
in the milky way
straightforward calculations show that
on average a new star lights up in this
area of space every two hours
the baby boom galaxy lies around 12.2
billion light years away from the earth
this means that what we see when
observing it is what was happening just
one and a half billion years after the
hypothetical big bang
it was a time when the universe was
still in the process of forming its
structure what is taking place in the
galaxy now is drastically different from
what we expect to observe there in
theory based on what we know about star
formation
the reasons why stars are produced here
at such an astounding rate are not known
yet but it is beyond any doubt that baby
boom is able to provide us with a lot of
information about the early stages of
our universe's evolution
one of the few galaxies one can observe
through an amateur telescope is the
so-called sombrero galaxy official
designation m104
it lies 30 million light years away from
the sun and its diameter is roughly four
times smaller than that of the milky way
the sombrero galaxy's outstanding
feature is a massive ring of dust and
cold hydrogen enveloping it
observations show that it is here that
most young stars are born
in addition to the peculiar ring the
sombrero galaxy is also remarkable for
its elaborate inner makeup
observations with a spitzer space
telescope show that most stars in this
galaxy form a structure typical of
elliptical galaxies
the stars here are mostly rather old
yellow and red dwarves the other stars
here on the other hand form spiral
structures concealed within an
elliptical cloud it is thought that this
phenomenon is a result of two galaxies
collision with their stars subsequently
and almost inevitably mingling together
it is incredible that the galactic
structures survived a merge of that
scale with minimal damage are none the
worst for this tremendous collision and
can still be observed
another peculiar feature in the sombrero
galaxy is exceptionally powerful x-ray
radiation emanating from the center
it is assumed that the accretion disk of
a supermassive black hole may be its
source
the mass of the hole is estimated to be
over a billion solar masses which makes
this enormous object one of the most
massive black holes known to science
today
there are also several sources of
tremendously high frequency or terahertz
radiation detected within the galaxy
although today their nature is still a
mystery
our galactic parade today is concluded
with yet another object boasting an
elaborate inner structure
the erie m64 galaxy rather aptly dubbed
the black eye galaxy
the nickname comes from a dark band of
cosmic dust that partly conceals the
galaxy's center from the observer on the
earth due to this line of cosmic dust as
well as the exceptionally bright active
nucleus it is impossible to estimate the
black eyes number of stars even roughly
what we do know is that it is
comparatively small and not so remote
its radius measures 25 000 light years
and it lies approximately 17 million
light years away from the milky way
the black eye galaxy is made up of two
well-defined parts
interestingly
the inner disc with a bulge rotate in
the direction opposite to that of the
outer ring
the most likely explanation for such a
bizarre makeup is that the galaxy formed
after two smaller ones collided and
merged in the distant past
admittedly it would take a combination
of a number of mutually independent
factors for such a fascinating and
well-defined structure to form
for example the progenitor galaxies
would have moved at specific velocities
and come together at a certain angle the
odds of a success would have been
minuscule
as a rule micro quasars are x-ray
binaries that is stellar systems made up
of two components
one of them is a regular star similar to
our sun
the other component is a compact object
like a black hole or a neutron star
matter in such micro quasars is
constantly in the process of
accumulating in the compact object which
is accompanied by occasional outflows of
matter at great speeds
these outflows are known as jets and the
nature of these jets reminds one of
processes taking place in regular
quasars
now it is not a regular occurrence in
ordinary quasars
meanwhile as the mass of a micro quasar
is smaller than that of an ordinary
quasar jets may originate here
practically on a daily basis
the principal difference between micro
quasars and ordinary quasars is in their
mass and the frequency of matter
outflows
for example the mass of the compact
components and micro quasars is
considerably smaller than the mass of
those in regular quasars it is just
several solar masses
just to compare the average mass of a
supermassive black hole in the center of
a quasar may be approximately as much as
a hundred million solar masses
as for the mass of the black hole likely
to be found in the center of ss-433
it must be just a few dozen cellular
masses
the accretion disk of a micro quasar is
intensely luminescent with emissions in
the optical and x-ray bands
a regular quasar is an astronomical body
boasting the highest luminosity among
other objects in the observable universe
according to contemporary scientific
views these celestial bodies are active
cores of galaxies where a supermassive
black hole sucks in matter all around it
thus forming an accretion disk
as for the disc itself it is a source of
very powerful luminosity
just to give you an idea its luminosity
may sometimes be hundreds of times as
intense as that of all stars in a galaxy
like ours combined
to date over 200 000 quasars have been
identified
we're able to observe some of these
quasars in the sky even without using a
telescope and so the rate of discovering
new objects of one or the other category
is another principal parameter by which
regular quasars and micro quasars differ
if we look at the list of known micro
quasars it contains just a few entries
so far
the first micro quasar was discovered
back in 1978
when a source of unusual radio and x-ray
emissions was detected by two
astronomers from the university of
cambridge as they were looking for
debris left over from supernovae
detected in the constellation aquila
this source was later dubbed ss-433
the object under scrutiny is an
eclipsing x-ray binary system
one of its components is likely to be a
black hole
as for the second component it is a star
of spectral type a
that is a main sequence dwarf star of a
whitish hue
it is assumed that this star's mass is
10 to 30 times that of our sun
and more likely than not the dwarf used
to be considerably heavier in the
earlier stages of its existence
its surface temperature is thought to be
anything from seven thousand to eleven
and a half thousand degrees kelvin
this temperature range is typical for
stars of this type it is actually its
temperature that gives the star its pale
yellow tint
in fact if we look at the stars closest
to the sun
then sirius altair and viega fall into
the same class as this star
ss433
is located within the supernova remnant
w50 sometimes also called the manatee
nebula
the age of this nebula is estimated at
approximately twenty thousand years
and the distance between the nebula and
the earth measures about eighteen
thousand light years
the jets from
ss-433 distort the clouds surrounding
the w-50 nebula
according to a certain theory the w50
nebula and the micro quasar ss-433 are
actually related and came to be as a
result of one in the same supernova
event which supposedly took place around
20 000 years ago
it takes either of the two objects in
the system 13.1 days to orbit the common
mass center
in fact the way the ss433 system works
is quite exciting with both components
constantly interacting with each other
matter from the second component that is
the regular star flows to the first
component or the primary supposedly a
black hole thus forming an accretion
disk around it as it spirals the matter
heats up to extreme temperatures and
emits x-rays
some part of this matter leaves the
system in two jets at the rate of
approximately 26 percent of the speed of
light
that is 79 000 kilometers per second
in 2019 thanks to the alma observatory
astronomers managed to get detailed
images of ss-433
it was clear from the emission structure
that the micro quasars jets themselves
are rather narrow and their shape is
irregular and has nodes
further studies of the object showed
that the shape of the jets is distorted
as a result of precession that is a
process when the jets slowly rotate on
their axis as they spiral
the diameter of either of the two jets
ejected from the micro quasar in two
opposite directions measures
approximately 5 000 times the diameter
of the solar system
as ss-433 is relatively close to the
earth it is particularly valuable to
scientists studying the phenomenon of
micro quasars
images beamed back by the alma
observatory showed its jets for the
first time
and it also helped establish the
direction these jets point at is never
the same
just like a top the spinning toy
gradually slows down they too rotate on
their axis which is perpendicular to the
plane of the accretion disk
the armor images boasted another
outstanding feature
the shape of ss-433 was predicted in
fine detail thanks to spectroscopic
measurements that had been done in 2018
using the global jet watch telescopes
and so the actual shape largely
corresponds to the new images where
ss-433 is really seen to have a shape
reminding one of a corkscrew
it isn't a rare occasion when jets like
that originate here or there in the
universe
as a rule jets of plasma also known as
relativistic jets are spewed out of the
centers of active galaxies quasars and
radio galaxies
when this occurs there are usually two
jets as such pointing in the opposite
directions
and this is exactly what we can observe
in the case of ss433
today the phenomenon of jets like that
wants deeper studying it is believed
that jets originate following the
interaction between magnetic fields and
the accretion disk around a black hole
or a neutron star
as for their size it may be staggeringly
enormous
in the case of the radio galaxy
3c120 for example the jet stretches for
at least several
sects away from its source
it is highly probable that in the future
the regular star in the ss-433 system
will shed its outer layer completely as
a result of the influence of the compact
object its core meanwhile will remain
hot and thus the star will qualify to be
called a hot sub dwarf
later the star is to be gradually sucked
in by the black hole and sooner or later
after this process is completed the
ss433 system will assume a classical
look
it will comprise just the compact object
the process of this system's evolution
will of course continue for thousands of
years so we have plenty of time to study
this phenomenon
and while the micro quasar ss-433 is
active we will have many opportunities
to carry out detailed observation that
would help us understand the nature of
this celestial object
let's keep in touch
the yellow dwarf which is known as the
sun and which gives us light and warmth
every single second is located on the
periphery of the milky way as it orbits
around the center of our galaxy it
follows the so-called co-rotation circle
this means that the rate of our sun's
movement accurately follows the rotation
of the galaxy's spiral arms which are
stellar nurseries
thanks to this fascinating
synchronization the solar system hardly
ever crosses the arms thus keeping a
safe distance away from harmful
supernova flares and the heat of active
stars
the diameter of this galactic orbit
matters too
if the sun were to lie closer to the
center of the milky way the great
abundance of heavy elements would have
rendered the forming planets too large
and massive
besides the galactic core's powerful
ionizing radiation would have thwarted
any attempts of life to evolve and
propagate on the surfaces of the planets
and their satellites
on the other hand the further from the
galactic center the much poorer the
chemical diversity of elements
in this case rocky planets of a rich
chemical composition like our earth
would never have been able to form the
sun would have been orbited solely by
gas giants or icy giants at best
there are some exciting coincidences
easily noticeable within the solar
system too for example consider this the
earth lies the ideal distance from the
sun and follows a stable orbit with a
small eccentricity our planet's orbital
trajectory is remarkably close to an
ideal circle if the trajectory's
diameter shifted as little as five
percent in any direction the planet
would either become ice bound or would
be shrouded in a dense cloud of water
vapor
the bottom line is that any advanced
life forms would cease to exist
in addition the sun itself has a number
of extremely important features
it is neither too hot nor too cold and
its life expectancy is considerably long
even though there forms a wide habitable
zone around a hot star its life
expectancy is generally small also its
ionizing radiation is much too powerful
golden stars like red dwarves on the
other hand are capable of sustaining a
habitable zone too narrow and generally
too close to themselves
that is why more often than not planets
within this zone are tidally locked to
their star and so are not equally heated
up with the temperatures on the two
sides drastically different
someone will probably offer a
counter-argument here to this effect it
isn't the earth that adapted to host
humans but rather life adapted to the
conditions already present here this is
a rather sensible point although if we
delve deeper into the structure of the
universe there are some facts that
cannot be accounted for by this
statement
first of all it should be mentioned that
celestial bodies can have stable orbits
only in three-dimensional space
in dimensions other than that the orbits
of electrons in a substance's atoms
become unstable
in other words electrons and atoms
either collapse to the core or fly away
into space
thus atoms cannot exist in a
multi-dimensional space
a universe of this sort would only have
radiation and freely floating elementary
particles
another point to consider is that there
are several fundamental values that all
contemporary physics is based on they
usually include the speed of light the
gravitational constant the planck's
constant the elementary charge
and the masses of the electron and the
proton
all these values have been arrived out
experimentally and today i consider to
be mutually independent
however modern science cannot say why
these values are exactly like that and
no other way
it is known that a free electron is a
bit heavier than a proton and electron
system
without this inequality there would be
no hydrogen around
because otherwise its atom would
immediately turn into a neutron
by the same token with no hydrogen
around no stars would be able to form in
the universe and heavier elements would
never exist either
with the values of the coulomb
interaction and the powerful interaction
slightly different from those gauged
today
no thermonuclear synthesis reactions in
stars interiors would be possible with
an increased gravitational constant
stars would compress far too strongly
this would inevitably produce a great
plethora of large and hot stars with a
short lifespan
after they burned out most matter in the
universe would be buried inside black
holes and neutron stars never to become
material to help form planets satellites
and other space objects
by contrast with a decreased
gravitational constant interstellar gas
would not be compressed enough to make
thermonuclear reactions self-sufficient
in this case stars would simply never
flare up and the universe would be
filled with giant brown dwarfs this time
a change in the electromagnetic
interaction coefficient in any direction
would render chemical reactions and
complex compounds virtually non-existent
on the other hand if the coulomb
interaction was stronger than it is now
there would be no elements heavier than
boron around
their nuclei would simply be torn apart
by proton's electromagnetic
repulsion heavy elements can form in the
universe thanks exclusively to a number
of factors favorably combined here are
some more exciting coincidences
consider this it is thanks to a special
state of carbon that helium is able to
transform into it known as carbon
resonance this phenomenon plays a
crucial role in the formation of heavy
elements and they're spreading across
the universe
it is thanks to carbon resonance that
stars go supernova and shed their outer
layers atoms born in their interiors are
scattered across space to form planets
satellites asteroids and other celestial
bodies
besides carbon is vital for the genesis
of life
only carbon is able to create long and
elaborate chains forming the base for
and forking out into incredibly diverse
chemical compounds
life as we know it can exist only when
based on organic compounds that would
never have formed but for carbon
so now it is clear that the universe
itself as well as life in it and
intelligent observers that is humans
came to be only thanks to a number of
fascinating and not readily obvious
coincidences theories that will be able
to account for this are usually beyond
the scope of physics and are rather to
do with philosophy
one of these is referred to as the
anthropic principle
even though the term itself was coined
only in 1973
the ideas it is based on had been voiced
much sooner for example we come across
this idea in the works of soviet
scientist grigori idlis dating back to
1958 where it is expressed to this
effect
what we observe is a part of the
universe that is not random a priori but
one that was made suitable for the
genesis and evolution of life by its
special structure
this vision is referred to as the weak
anthropic principle
much later on the so-called strong
anthropic principle was formulated
according to which the universe is
supposed to have certain properties that
are favorable for the evolution of
intelligent life
or to put it differently an observer is
needed for the universe to exist the
latter formulation is based on an idea
used in quantum physics the observer
plays a crucial role because their
presence dramatically influences the
behavior of particles that is why the
observer is indispensable in any quantum
physics experiment we might also see it
put this way
the laws of the universe are the way
they are because we can exist only in
the universe the way it is
the anthropic principle implies that
theoretically there may exist other
universes out there or else other parts
of this single universe that would have
a different set of physical laws however
it is that either mankind is not able to
observe those areas or those
hypothetical worlds cannot get real
without an observer this assumption may
be further developed into a multiverse
theory or a hypothesis where basic
physical constants may change their
values as time goes by
still observations of the areas of the
universe visible to us show that the
fundamental values remain unchanged
the concept of a multiverse defies
description in the scope of science
generally speaking the anthropic
principle lies largely beyond the scope
of the scientific view of the world and
requires a metaphysical approach
stanislav lam commented on this to this
effect
it's an attempt to account for the
unknown using the unknown
also it is evident that the anthropic
principle clashes with the mediocrity
principle the latter states that the
area of space observable to humans isn't
anything extraordinary and there would
be lots and lots of similar stretches
within the universe the milky way for
example doesn't boast any particularly
unique structural features and its
position in the large-scale structure of
the universe doesn't particularly stand
out among billions upon billions of
other galaxies
in addition
there is the principle of space
homogeneity accepted in contemporary
physics which means that natural laws
are really the same from point to point
in space
the correctness of this postulate is
confirmed by countless observations of
the world around us
mankind has been stirred by these
questions since times a memorial are we
alone in the universe is our home planet
unique or are there more earth-like
worlds in the milky way or is what we
see just a kind of backdrops with
whatever there is behind them being
something incredible that would defy our
understanding and therefore appears to
be carefully concealed from us by the
universe
science cannot give satisfying answers
to any of these questions yet
otherwise it would probably bring about
a downright revolution in our perception
of the world and upgrade our cognition
to a whole new level
as it is everyone is entitled to their
own personal opinion
unfortunately space tours like that will
be confined to science fiction for a
long time
we're virtually just scratching the
surface in space exploration
and the future definitely holds lots and
lots of amazing discoveries both in the
solar system and beyond
every new step forward gives answers and
prompts yet more questions
and this is the way the ultimate puzzle
the universe is slowly being put
together piece by piece
you